any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
some upbeat music for today's guest who
is uh quickly becoming one of my
favorite
characters and harassable character
in all venues wherever i encounter him
online
in cyberspace we have yet to meet in
person he just got back from doing an
inside tour of a volcano in iceland able
to get to that we're talking to lee
cronin he is professor he is the chair
the regis chair of chemistry
at uh a renowned university university
of glasgow where there have been some
scientists maybe we'll talk about social
media and a famous scientist from there
i believe uh james clark maxwell or not
far away perhaps
lee how are you doing today across the
world did you survive the volcanic trip
it looks like you held up pretty good
you get a little bit of a tan you got a
vodka can we did get a volcano i was
lucky to get the volcano not in cloud
but in daylight in sun and erupting so
it was brilliant
yeah those some of those drone videos
that you shared on twitter and lee is a
prolific tweeter and not just about
science although there's plenty of hard
science there but also about philosophy
academia um and supporting um young
people in science which i really love
and he takes to heart what i believe is
our uh is our moral obligation lee i
think you share this that scientists
have an obligation to share what we do
with the public because the public pay
for our our exp our uh basically our
adventures right so we we let's be
honest you'd be doing this for free as
would i um so anything we get is above
and beyond what we really have a right
to expect agree or disagree
i agree it is expensive though
it is i want to talk about academia as
an industry in in just a little bit but
i want to begin with a recap and i'll
put a link to our conversation or the
conversation that you graciously
provided for my video why is dna twisted
where you make a very substantial and
delightfully received cameo appearance
and it's to talk about your what i felt
were provocative comments on chirality
but what do i know i'm just a simple
physicist i'm not a chemist
first of all we always hear this
derogatory thing from from physicists
like dirac that you know his equation
explains all of chemistry and most of
biology or maybe it's the other way
around um
what how do you react to such statements
i think that um physics is about to
change because physics right now as
opposed cannot
explain life
and i think that physics chemistry and
biology are actually the same study
and i think dirac is actually saying
about his equation can't achieve it for
reasons we can discuss and it's to do
about the operational memory associated
with that equation but physics is
changing and i think chemistry and
biology need to change with it as well
when you say that uh it needs to change
to accommodate life would it be
something new like a hybrid in
biophysics or something or would we
really change you know the equations of
general relativity
um i think the latter but i'm not really
qualified enough yet um and i would say
that there are physics does the job
really well describes the universe
really well but it doesn't really
explain us but that's not enough yet
because the gaps are not substantial but
there are some kind of um some gaps
which are probably above my not
necessarily just my pay grade but also
my training
and i don't like to kind of talk about
beyond my training but as a chemist i
like the second law but the second law
i don't understand why the universe has
to have a second law and i don't
understand why physicists can think
there should be an origin of the
universe but yet they can't accept time
as a thing so when you look at dirac and
time you understand that they didn't get
the story they only understand it's only
post um
reductive it doesn't predict the future
so we need to understand how life
emerges from dead stuff from low memory
stuff from the fundamental particles
going up and i think because physics
isn't able to do that yet there's a gap
and i'm not saying that physics is wrong
i just always wanted to be a physicist
but i was never smart enough at school
and i'm wondering if they might let me
in
do you have any cool uh quotes from
chemists you know kind of uh dunking on
physicist or is it only does it only go
in one direction
no i mean i think chemists think they're
the central science but i think that
chemists do think they do the real
material science
again because there is all this tacit
knowledge but i i don't really like to
make it a competition because i think
the the superiority
complexes that some people have is
anti-science and anti-um
the discussion where i think you know
some people very senior physicists
you've interviewed you've had on your
podcast are not don't make things
impenetrable but they are so sure of the
standard or the core model that they're
not open to revision so i want to think
one thing that i think that is really
important is that lee smolin is correct
about time and chemists have time built
in time is a thing
time comes before space
where for physics time is an add-on it's
something you have to use later and
that's a and that i think where is one
of the new one of the small kinks
in the in the in the armor that really i
would like to get into as a chemist i
can usefully contribute to rather than
saying relativity is wrong and i've got
a better sp better theory of gravity
which is clearly untrue i don't
uh yeah especially after your drone fell
into the volcano caldera that was
embarrassing uh your ex exploits with
gravity but i think you're right you
know physicists almost view atoms as a
nuisance you know it's almost it would
be better cleaner nicer if atoms didn't
exist right um time is somewhat more uh
problematic as you say there are people
that have statements about time as as
you noted um and lisa mullen has an idea
about time and um and i almost feel like
time might be like consciousness like
we're not ever going to develop a really
solid foundation
for either one it's basically pointless
when you hear about things uh in entropy
the past hypothesis when you hear about
you know these these are just like last
gasps and i want to get into that we
talk about religion because obviously
religion has a much easier way of
establishing initial conditions than
physics math or or chemistry but but
you're absolutely right and i think you
have this way of looking at things that
is very
foundational on one hand but very um
very grandiose in a good sense in that
you're looking at these big picture
topics and i think you know i really
didn't appreciate until you and i
started our discussions that you know
time is really intimately connected to
these atoms that are so uh so so
pernicious to physicist and in that we
really wouldn't have a way of
distinguishing the past from the future
we always talk about a pendulum you know
swinging back and forth can you tell me
where the pendulum swung back and
started swinging no can you tell me if
the movie's going in forwards or reverse
no you can't tell me that unless you
look at their infrared signature and you
see well these things are warming up in
an atmosphere now if there's no
atmosphere you still can't determine the
arrow of time but we put these things in
by hand and and it sort of feels like it
is becoming you know hopeless or
pointless
and that the more we hear about it the
more we're getting back to fundamentals
so to speak but then everything kind of
has to emerge by fiat so what do you
think is the ultimate um if chemistry
were separate from physics where would
chem what would chemistry tell us just
as chemistry without relying on physics
or time and uh what would it tell us
about the origin of life
and maybe maybe first of all what is
life if you were a chemist
uh not
okay yeah i i think the time question
isn't isn't hopeless but i think that's
i sense that's another podcast so let's
just restrict ourselves to chemistry i
say what chemistry is able to do is to
record configurations
what's happened in a previous point
and because of the way that
combinatorial explosions happen
that those combinatorial explosions
basically start to provide an active
memory i would say this the physics has
a very low memory to do stuff with then
chemistry gives you a bit more memory
and so that means you can connect atoms
together you can make molecules you can
make polymers you can put in sequences
and they can read out
current conditions the environment and
then
something about the environment causes
those molecules to be challenged to be
burned turn back into their constituent
atoms or to survive that selects all
that attrition
and and maybe somehow act on the other
molecules so what you get is this
interaction between matter
that's undergoing a uh
increase in the number of bits
associated with its history
and then
this is what we don't understand i think
chemistry can offer physics and then
maybe biology is that
life is not on off switch
life seems to be a continuum of um
information that is collected in a
molecular memory
that is collected in the past and then
can act in the future
uh um to basically
open up the state space so it's almost
why and that's why my notion of time
goes back to physics because suddenly
chem
physics without chemistry has no future
in terms of the state space doesn't
increase
chemistries does something weird to the
what um
um stuart kaufman and sarah walker and
others would call the adjacent possible
in that you there are things you can
imagine or the molecules can get access
to just just merely the act of having
access to those configurations allows
other things to be possible that weren't
possible before this is a really hard
concept and to start to get there we
have to make the transition from
chemistry to biology but let's keep the
chemistry
why is it that chemistry might give the
answer to the origin of life well it
seems to be that
like i would say something heretical
even though i was supposed to be a
chemist i would say that the origin of
life hasn't on earth has nothing to do
with chemistry per se it's just the
lowest level which life could emerge
in a substrate seems to be with atoms
connected together on earth that's all
we know so that means we have covalent
bonds non-covalent interactions and
we're going to start to have a memory of
the past to unravel the the present and
then at some point
when all when the attrition in the
environment you've got the erosion
things being protected um you've got
molecules basically being burned
molecules becoming bigger
and bigger but then once those molecules
become functional when they can work
together in networks
maybe in a cellular object maybe in a
soap bubble maybe in a piece of lava
suddenly you have a network and if that
network now can be propagated from one
space to another could that be the first
kind of evolutionary dynamic in fact
does evolution
transcend biology but gets instantiated
with the bond
and so i think that chemistry starts to
evolve to discover selection and then
evolution producing biology and that's
why the origin of life is such an
interesting and contentious question
because everything's like you and i say
ah let's have a debate about first of
all we just imagine there's nothing in
the sky we can't see anything except our
sun
we look up and say hey brian how did
that form and you're like well there's
only one sun isn't there right we need
to work out the precise conditions how
much hydrogen what was the nucleation
site what was collapsing would be
obsessing about whether there was any
helium or anything else coming in and
maybe chucking some other elements but
then suddenly someone takes a shroud off
and you see stars everywhere and if
you're really lucky you see stars being
born and dying every day in the universe
and suddenly you can think statistically
and i wonder if the problem the origin
of life is we're talking about a single
event where we need to be looking at in
the universe and say where's life
popping up where's life dying out what
are the characteristic controls and how
is it instantiated
yeah i think you're right you know these
things always bring up the classic
chicken or egg
um conundrum and i figured i actually
solved it lee i solved the chicken and
egg because based on the advice of my uh
my ten-year-old he said dad just order a
chicken on amazon order an egg on amazon
and see which comes first
then you'll know
uh but uh but in reality yeah these
one-off things and what's the other
one-off origin story it's of course the
origin of the universe what's another
origin story origin of consciousness
these things where we only have one you
know exemplar one you know stewie
generous event
process uh concept or or instantiation
you're right um and so i think some of
these things are destined forever to the
the you know the dustbin of kind of like
oh they're really obsessing about
something that's meaningless and maybe
we won't know that till the 23rd century
doesn't stop us from writing papers and
getting you know tenure and stuff like
that but um what is the simplest thing
that's alive i mean i hear sometimes a
virus is alive maybe it's not i hear ai
from my friend max tegmark is alive
but what is the simplest thing that's
alive
so i i would say that that is the wrong
question right because i think the thing
is as i a virus is definitely
um alive when it's in your cell
and i think um my robotic lawnmower is
definitely a looks alive when it runs
around its electric field and appears to
make decisions it's not sentient but it
is and isn't it the robotic designer put
some sentience into it and so what we're
doing is we're thinking about the
lineage of life in the wrong way life is
not an isolated phenomena life
um as my colleague i think sarah walker
would say is a planetary phenomenon so
what that means is the planet somehow
was able to start producing
selection
on a planet and the same with
consciousness actually and we'll go
through that so you have the origin of
life or the the development of
complexity starting the evolution
starting to get module dependency built
in robustness
because an astronaut
if you're an ass if bezos was an
astronaut but that john grunsfeld a
friend of mine was an astronaut real
rational he fixed the hubble a few times
in fact he came to my regis or north
creation
and showed the video which would never
have an astronaut come to you you know
when you're giving a lecture because
they just i mean it was brilliant but
what what john and i were debating a lot
is like when the astronaut is in space
is the astronaut alive or dead well
functionally the metabolic the astronaut
is alive but when the oxygen runs out
the astronaut is dead
and if the astronauts had no children on
earth and they can't get back to earth
and have a family their lineage is gone
and so what we've got to do is stop um
i think we are asking the wrong question
about if there's any
uh simplest unit of life i think it is a
continuum and they and there is various
module dependencies so obviously a
bacterium some bacteria are pretty good
the cindia bacteria made by craig venter
was barely alive it had to have all the
support system had to have amino acids
provided to it he said it was like a
minimal life but it wasn't it was kind
of a souped-up virus
um but our viruses are light and so i
think the question to be replaced to say
not is something alive or not but was it
produced by evolution
so the ai we have of course it was
produced by evolution human programmer
built it okay of course and i and i
think when we start to change the
question from what is living to what is
evolved
the question becomes much more
clarifying and substantial and we get
away from almost a metaphysical
religious discussion to how can we test
for evolution how can we test for
information how can we test this lineage
of possibilities but is that tantamount
to as i say giving up because
at some level you know at least in many
people's minds maybe not in a proper
scientist's mind you know the most
interesting question is not you know
which came first the chicken or the egg
it's uh it's essentially you know how
did the dna or how did the first living
whatever you consider that thing that
kicked off
uh the evolutionary process what was
that what was it was it pure molecules
in motion was it some assembly like john
conway would develop in in the computer
what uh because the claim of course as
you know it is it does devolve into into
debates about origins and then origin
nators i.e gods uh so you know isn't is
isn't that kind of shifting the goal
post to the right let me pull it back no
no i'm not dismissing i i'm saying
life is like the so the emergence of
life in the universe
should my feeling is
my hope is my intuition is okay these
are all unqualified we will qualify them
um as obvious and simple as these the
birth of stars so again let's not obsess
about whether there's a single star what
i mean is
what do we need on a planet for the
planet to become evolving and living i'm
not saying so i'm actually saying
something far more general saying
it's a bit like i'm trying to
characterize the force of selection in
the universe not as in a physical force
but a memory right going forward
um i think they are obsessing about the
origin of life on earth is interesting
as much as obsessing about the origin of
our sun but where how does how do stars
form where do they fall where can we
find them what's the metric and that
that's what i'm so i'm not whining in
fact i'm narrowing the goal post to say
does it evolve
can we get it there putting life on mars
really human life on mars really
complicated what about putting an origin
of life bomb on mars and making our own
martians
right what about making life on the moon
and but not trying to force life there
to say what resources what do we need to
do to the stuff
so it actually can emerge
as a and i'm not saying you can't have
more than one life emerging on the
planet at the same time it's just
redundancy built in
no and uh just to remind you know so the
listeners i'm sure you know this uh
charles darwin a man of some renown in
the origins of uh species at least he
wrote in to his friend
he wrote it is mere rubbish to consider
the origin of life we might as well
consider the origin of matter and and of
course you know my colleagues and i work
on that every day and we understand the
process by which matter came into
existence but we don't understand
the fundamental conditions that were
initiative of the origin of matter in
other words we understand the processes
like you mentioned with the sun and the
gravitational collapse and so forth but
we we understand the properties of big
bang nuclear synthesis i've done a talk
about that on the podcast but um but we
haven't really gotten to the initial
condition even inflation is not time
equals zero and i think those things
captivate but again it may be it may be
kind of the wrong questions to ask one
question i found very provocative in
your contribution to my video why is dna
twisted we'll put a link to it here or
maybe here
whatever handedness i need to use
it was that your claim is that
the question of whether or not you know
chirality is needed to produce life is
really not a good one can you explain
that and and whether or not well which
came first the chirality or the life
the life or the process that gave rise
to sufficient symmetry breaking to
choose for chirality and i think i've
been thinking a lot about this
um
the
the reason for me saying this is it is
actually based upon actually relatively
good statistical physics and chemistry
in the universe you if you have a
process well there's two things you can
do or three things number one you can
have a process that produces stuff that
isn't chiral and then a process can
happen to make it chiral but then you
have equal hands
or you can have a process or make an
excess
that process to make an excess as we
know from the way the physical
interactions require lots of contingency
circularly polarized light will produce
things in very low concentrations so
what is more likely
a process of some kind of cosmic
chiral source or the fact that the
process of selection happenstance in a
in an inorganic environment just so
happens um to favor one one process over
another over many events and it's a bit
like a cook flicking a coin
it's a bit like me saying hey brian i'm
going to give you a coin the more you
flick this coin
the more like you the more heads you're
going to get so keep flicking it and
after a while you'll go from you know
equal heads tails to just heads
or to say here's a coin flick it you're
always going to get heads you're going
to be going hang on how did this happen
why where did that information come from
and i think the problem with requiring
chirality at the beginning is somehow
requiring us to get a really large
amount of information
here's why
for physicists it's easy to imagine
having a left or right-handed process in
in your if you're looking at em wave or
something in chemistry
if you're looking at molecule you've got
a left or right hand side but think of
the energy and the information that goes
into
selecting the molecule
separating it from the mixture and
enriching it and going around in a cycle
and doing that and continuing to do that
and when you think about the state
machine or the evolutionary machine
that's required to do that
the statistics doesn't add up
it can't happen spontaneously it's like
asking for a broken egg to rebuild
itself it could happen if you're if
you're a very very optimistic and
long-lived statistician but it doesn't
the second law doesn't allow it so the
reason
why i'm very sure that chirality is not
needed is we need energy and
fluctuations and processes and that will
give rise to a chiral excess as a
selection dynamic now why well as life
starts to make molecules and
configurational spaces searched there is
utility becoming handed because it's
easier to fold it's easier to plug and
play it's easier to have a a kind of
lock and key relationship with the
molecules whereas if all the molecules
were disordered you'd get no selection
so selection produces chirality
and chirality does not produce selection
because it's in the wrong so it's almost
teleological in nature
my question i've always had for a
biochemist or i know you're technically
an inorganic chemist but you dabble a
lot in uh in
organic chemistry or you know synthetic
uh synthesis of life why is folding
necessary i mean i always hear it it
sort of seems just like a tautology like
proteins have to fold uh to activate and
then but obviously proteins had to be
you know made originally with i don't
wanna get into anymore i'm actually
quite sick of eggs
and chickens and so forth they make me
they make me nauseous
it's just
think about the process of assembly
let's just say we're going to have a
we're going to have a polymer let's just
say the polymer has got some amino acids
and let's restrict ourselves to a small
number and you want this polymer to fold
up say into an x or a y or a z let's
just say that and let's just say the x
is good at one thing the y is good at
one thing and the z is good at another
so those folds give you with the same
atoms
if you fold different you get different
functions so it's like a compression so
you're able to use less stuff and just
refold it so that's why proteins are
folded so they can they have different
function so now selection in the
environment this polymer is unraveled in
some way it gets folded by the
environment and can be good at
protecting say the let's say it's in a
cell from being attacked by something or
it's good for binding a phosphate or
diphosphate or triphosphate for an
energies currency to basically provide
some free energy and so what you've got
is you need to re re reuse this
materials a bit like saying
we could
make our alphabet bigger in fact abandon
the need for an alphabet and we'll just
basically teach each other words without
any compression but it wouldn't be very
efficient and there'll be a limited
amount of sophistication that we
wouldn't be i don't know we might be
able to say hello and goodbye and
food or whatever or emergency but we
won't be able to say much more so
refolding is like the alphabet of
biology to basically say more complex
sentences and paragraphs so you can do
more and that's all it is now if you
have chirality and folding one direction
it's just you don't get disorder it's a
bit like you you go
it's a property that you have in in
three-dimensional space you're much
better qualified to express than i am of
basically organizing material so they re
the the spatial relationship between the
objects
is conserved such that you can continue
to be functional whether so your x is
good at being as x and your y is good at
being y no that does and
thank you for that lucid explanation the
the issue you know i want to point out
is obviously uh there are languages like
hawaiian only has 13 uh 13 characters 13
letters in the hawaiian alphabet and
lasting check we can have great
conversations in hawaiian that can
express all the uh lavishness and
grandiosity of our universe
with just those 13 letters obviously dna
has four letters and you could do
anything with with two letters
effectively as you and sarah have talked
about um you know that this is the
ultimate form of compression is is not
being um not being resplendent but
really being compressing into as much
information as to as little a space as
possible so maybe yeah the folding
process can be thought of as a
compression as you say
so that's very that's very helpful i
want to ask now though about some of the
controversies again not to talk about
chickens or eggs but more to talk about
um debates and debating
from a purpose of wanting to come to
understanding and i i don't know this
guy jim tour that you guys uh debated uh
together on unbelievable i was on that
show with a friend of mine steve meyer
but i take it you guys don't really see
eye to eye
and i always have problems by the way
lee with these you know when i talk with
my friends in the christian apology you
know sort of uh movement and intelligent
designers typically are uh predominantly
dominated by by christians and that you
know it'll start with something
plausible like everything that had a
design you know had a designer then it
will have maybe that that designer has a
personal stake in your life and um in
morality and so forth and then and then
jesus christ and and that's hard for me
because i'm a practicing jew as you know
but it's uh it's a different we have
different kinds of of interpretations of
things and just like you have in your
textbooks you know you have this um you
know very very long thorough footnotes
in your papers your nature paper which
we'll get to
it's very thorough and very well
documented because you can't understand
it without that it's not enough to just
write this and so forth and so in
judaism we have this other tradition
called the talmud which contains all the
hyperlinks uh
to all the information and otherwise
it's almost understandable and so i find
it very difficult to talk to people
who are dogmatically you know wanting to
promulgate the christian apologetics
that you know will somehow lead the
teleology will lead from the big bang
to jesus christ but absent that your
debate which did involve james tour
talking about christianity and so forth
uh uh was very fascinating to me but um
but what i always hear are criticisms of
of his point and then they'll be retorts
so he'll say you know you can't prepare
these life in a lab
and you can't use that as an analog here
at uc san diego we had stanley miller
and harold uri they worked together here
at ucsd uh and uh of course the miller
urey experiment uh is it was very it's
still used as kind of like proof that
life can spontaneously emerge from the
conditions on the early earth now we
know the conditions of the earth were
not like the miller yuri experiment
that's okay you know they still accept
the basic premise could happen uh but
tell me where are we and where is this
debate going uh they say you need
information that the basis of life is
somehow there's some information and
there's no source of information without
a mind what was that debate with jim
tour centered on so i think you
summarize it really well uh and the way
i come at these debates and say is i'm
i'm
i i have a lot of religious friends and
a lot of people i like to talk to and i
kind of have a rule and and maybe it's a
really crude philosophical and say if
you can't falsify it it's not really
science right and there's lots and it
kind of all the borderline right we can
there's a bits there and i'm saying if
you're coming from a belief point of
view we all have beliefs and the beliefs
you either have to accept
we can work backwards and there are some
beliefs in physics right we can't yet
falsify but we're hoping to get there
and what i think jim was trying to do
what james tall was trying to do was to
mix up
the belief the kind of that kind of
rules of the debate to kind of
kind of kind of create a confusion and i
really found that
actually quite disrespectful because
actually i don't know everything i don't
know why we're here
and and i think that he kind of lost a
really important
um
point right where actually origin of
life has some big open questions it's
certainly not about whether maker comes
but actually it's about i think the
catholic church realizing that we you
know weren't the center of the universe
and then what we do in physics going on
and i don't i don't really understand
what his point was other than to say oh
the cell is so complicated it couldn't
arise by chance and when you go in your
lab and you do experiments you interact
in your lab therefore you're cheating
and we're saying well of course we know
we're cheating and that's the point some
origin of life chemists are actually
cheating and they don't realize it and
that's actually stopping us from getting
to the real mechanism other origin of
life chemists are really obsessing about
the geology in earth
and that's really important and we're
kind of missing this bigger question so
there's this obviously in every science
there's a debate and physics is about
the origin of the universe and so what
jim was trying to do is to take the
debate in
i'm not an origin of life chemistry i
want to make life in real time in
organic life let's go let's make a
little star in a bottle right you know i
want to demonstrate that the process of
making life is possible right now isn't
somehow weirdly contingent
um and show it and then when if i cheat
to do it i'll say well how much did i
need to cheat
could is this plausible on mars is it
plausible on venus
in the same way that if we made a star
in the lab like i think we have tried to
do in the fusion labs say oh is it
plausible in the universe right it's
exactly the same argument so i think
that there are many complex parts but i
think that this using the the fact the
cell is so complicated is really a
forgets one really important thing it's
a real portrayal actually it's really
nonsensical and we'll get there
and that is to say this that life is
special on earth that there that
that's one thing and it's a one-off will
never happen again well they don't
understand that life on earth is special
it is a one-off because it's a series of
unique events
so biology my argument is confined to
earth there is no biology elsewhere in
the universe because biology is defined
by the ribosome dna the right helicity
blah blah blah but there's life
everywhere in the universe and when you
find an earth-like planet with the same
elements wouldn't it be wonderful to go
and have a look at what
solution
has been found on that planet it won't
be exactly ours will be different
and i think that that's only when we
start to do that in the laboratory and
say hey jim look we've made life but
it's not what you think it's another one
look isn't that weird isn't our ribosome
different and i think when we start to
see that we'll push the debate back more
constructively but kind of origin of
life is kind of trapped in this we must
take the car
and decompose it and say where did the
steering wheel come from where did the
door come from and so there's a lot of
different complaints going on there and
i i think the intelligent designers are
being fairly nefarious
and you know and when i realized that i
just disengaged and said well look hey
i i i know
i i'm i'm an educated idiot or i'm i'm
not an educated idiot i'm i'm educated
to understand what i don't know
and what we have to understand is how to
reduce that uncertainty and that's where
that debate kind of you know i i don't
know what you felt about it but i felt
that
slightly
you know disrespected and and you know
it was obviously for his crew right for
his for his uh um people following him
nevertheless i think you know there's
always this um you know god of the gaps
pushback on on the religious uh but
there's almost an equivalent you know
god of the multi or you know multiverse
of the gaps or panspermia of the gaps or
miller yuri and of the gaps and i i do
feel like the sometimes it can go too
far on the other side and i wonder if
you could you know steel man if you were
channeling your james tour it doesn't
sound like you want to
but you know when you hear about these
things like michio kaku's new book the
god equation he was on my podcast i'll
put a link to his episode over here um
you know at the end of it he talks about
you know thomas aquinas's questions
about design and and he basically says
that like evolution created life and it
doesn't sound like too far off from what
you were saying i don't believe that you
you know i think it's semantic in some
level but um i think if i could
summarize you it might be
uh things that are alive are processes
that participate in evolution either
they're the
creator of it uh they engender it they
manifest it they instantiate whatever
you wanna say they participate somehow
in evolution however you know on their
side they're saying well you don't have
evolution without information you have
dna it has information you find a watch
it was obviously put together even fred
hoyle who was a famous you know atheist
most of his life he made the 747
argument he made
arguments about uh you know the the um
the fine-tuning of as as we know the
carbon miracle that allows carbon to
form in this very narrow resonance the
oil resonance um so can you steel man
their position i mean is there anything
besides the god of the gaps that you
know they have going for them or is it
really you know just a matter of time
before we a scientist really come up
with an answer to these ultimate
questions which i think are deservedly
given that title of
i'm
i think you're right we will come up
with a solution and to that and i think
it is hard to still man it but i'll i'll
do one because i think we should
we will do one because actually that
plays into what i'm trying to do as well
and trying to de-anthropomorphize the
origin of life studies so right now
we're saying okay it's
easy to imagine that once we solve
um
for rna that basically the problem is
done okay and what i would argue from
their point of view is rna is quite a
complex molecule and it's hard to get
there and why are we demanding rna
what we should be saying because the rna
is saying hey we don't care about rna in
fact we don't care about the molecules
at all what we care about is the process
of selection selection starts with you
know quarks it does just there's just
not many states to go right it's you
just as you know then you get your atoms
and then you get your bonds and when you
get bonds you get molecules and when you
get molecules you get a commentary
explosion and then you can get a
selection and as soon as you get
selection you start to kick-start the
process of evolution and what biology is
biology is merely a an efficient funnel
for fast evolution
and it's a bit likely it's like the slow
accretion of information and i think
what we have to do with the steel
manning of the oh yeah the rna looks
improbable but then when we realize that
rna is improbable but we go all the way
back but we don't need information at
the beginning we just need molecules
bumping into each other in some rock
some symmetry breaking that occurs
naturally accretion of that
and suddenly random fluctuations turn
into information how
so let's say i randomly push a piece of
snow down a hill
and it bounces off a wall and builds a
snowman
i only recognize that to me a snowman
after the fact right it's suddenly that
random event but let's say building a
snowman allows a snowman because it can
then i don't know tumble over in a
certain way can make other snowmen
and suddenly that rat and that snowman
can then go back to the top of the hill
and make another one so when a random
process
gives rise to a replication
randomly that stabilizes that process so
it can go back
and then undergo selection through
mutation
that's how you get life from nothing and
that is what we have to do in the
laboratory nothing less
than going from we have to literally
break the second law but we don't the
second law doesn't need to be broken
because time exists
and when time exists you don't need a
stupid second law
right that's the that's but you then
show this secretion of information and
that's how it works and and to get away
from time and breaking second law just
provide some energy so if you have an
energy source and stuff you will get
memory over time if you get a commentary
explosion in the molecular space so
that's kind of a way of actually still
mailing it say rna is not the answer and
then showing how chemistry can provide
roots to not just one origin of life but
many and my job my colleagues job the
job of science we need to go make life
in the lab many different life forms not
just based on this life we know now but
it will be different and that's going to
be exciting if i can get my lab tomorrow
and show that evolution can occur in a
completely different system
even if i created it
i think i would be able to convince most
skeptics about origin of life not that
had a religious angle that the phenomena
selection is beyond works beyond
um biology a round bottom flask a piece
of glass a cavity some energy some stuff
i think no one would deny me what do you
say to those that say
you know well we have no example of life
being produced from these uh situations
even if you were to do it you know the
craig bentner who's a neighbor you know
kind of in la jolla uh to ucsd uh you
know those who say well you started with
these highly purified reagents that you
bought from alditch or or fisher and
then you put it in a autoclave you know
test tube and
you prepare it wasn't like darwin's
little warm little pond very much at all
right so
what about that objection well
so that's very important and that's what
i'm saying i'm still manning it from the
rna point of view that is correct i
don't like that i think that you're it's
too much like saying um trying to you
know understand someone's art exhibit
and they say no they they put this here
because that reason no what we're doing
in my lab and this is where miliuri went
wrong right and this is where origin of
life actually became
a
origin of life and astrobiology is still
pre-paradigm right we don't know what
life is so it's great that people love
it and working on it but we just don't
know what it means it's like the same
problem as electricity right we know
there's sparks out there we know there's
charge carriers but we just don't know
what life is so what i'm doing in my lab
and lots of new labs are doing is we are
generating the simplest taking the
simplest molecules so sim so least
number of bonds and basically
turning them into crap just baking
making tar just making a mess
and then showing
over time recursively in cycles that
mess
not only
um doesn't get messier it gets simpler
and more complicated
so this is really important you're
saying well hang on but isn't that mess
complex sure but a mess is
a mess is not
highly complex it's just a mess
there so what i mean is let's say i give
you a budget of a trillion carbon atoms
you could just make a trillion you know
a few hundred thousand molecules but if
suddenly i could take those carbon atoms
and funnel them into one molecule to
make say i don't know let's say taxol
which is one of the you know a natural
product from pacific yew tree which is a
very good anti-cancer drug it's got a
very particular structure
beautiful molecule if i could funnel all
that into a complex molecule
then an evolutionary process had to
produce it so what we need
simple stuff carbon dioxide methane
hydrogen miliuri go for it
the where mila uri went wrong and we did
this in my lab
is they didn't have the earth's crust
they had no real way of accelerating
doing catalysis and no cycles it was
just a snapshot it was an obvious
combinatorial experiment
um for me not for them it was paradigm
shifting not to take it away from your
colleagues so now what we need to do is
miliuri type chemistry in a random
environment with a mineral environment
recirculate and then see how selection
starts and look at that explosion of a
mess and say look mess
and then keep going keep going say oh
gosh the mess is simplifying less
components but hey look at the average
complexity of the components it's going
up up up what's going on and that is the
marker that we're looking for in the lab
right now which will indicate that
evolutionary dynamic is becoming
established it's akin to
i'll do it in lego analytics i love lego
we make all these layout let's make lego
star wars melon vulcans tie fighters
everything and you say right
i think the origin of life people just
love star wars they say i'm going to
make a millennium falcon you know that's
my template i'm going to find a way of
making there right so they're adding in
the falcons are different there's a
different uh series
the millennium falcon
but then i'm saying hey let's not have
let's have no bias what we want to make
we're going to put all the lego blocks
in the big fat and stir them
and they'll just make a mess but if you
keep stirring and you have a template
suddenly the lego will accrete
and grow
and some of that lego that happens to
replicate itself
as you know statistical physics you'll
have a phase transition to do around the
system and suddenly you'll start to
generate complexity and kind that
staircase and i think that's what we
have to do in the lab nothing more and
nothing less we have to generate
complexity from nothing
using energy and stuff and so you and i
talk a lot about you know when when
you're my kind of um what do you call
that guy cyrano de bergerac you know uh
you you kind of provide me some tips to
talk to my biology colleagues when they
come on the show and that's really
helpful and you're always respectful
about it you always ask what's the crisp
test what's the test for which there
will be found evidence to either
substantiate or refute
xyz's claim and i've had on a lot of you
know the physicists that deal in traffic
in the origin of time origin of life and
you've helped me kind of framework and
and uh get the proper framework for some
of my questions i thank you for that um
but i want to ask you um
science by its nature is necessarily
tentative
in today's age i want to do a thought
experiment with you uh take you back to
your countrymen a young james clerk
maxwell and he's operating in 1864 and
he comes up with four equations which
oliver heavyside and others would later
transmute to the world literally
and revolutionize our understanding of
fundamental forces of nature and the
unification of forces as well
and these are the course the famous
maxwell's equations there's four of them
and they're beautiful um now imagine
maxwell's around and uh twitter somehow
was around back then and maxwell is
there and he like you is a scotsman
who's not afraid to tweet and uh and
share his his bold opinions and his
genius with the world and so he says i
have this new theory and i know what
you're going to say
uh but uh but the way that it works is
there these little gears and there are
these little whirlpools in space and
there's this ether type substance and we
don't understand that um and then he
would have roundly been laughed out of
society right and we would have had a
complete
complete uh devastating effect on our
understanding and progress in physics um
you talk a lot about you know kind of uh
ideas and how to test them but imagine
we applied the cronin test to maxwell in
1864. he would have flunked it uh
because there are no little gears and
stuff and so you would have thrown the
uh the the egg out with the bath water
right so so tell me lee where do we draw
this line between
necessarily tolerating a theory for some
amount of time uh
versus you know putting the hammer down
early so that we can get onto right
thinking in a more proper fashion
yeah that's a really i mean that's not
just a question for kind of you know
chemistry it's for all science right for
the way we're doing this and i've been i
mean um
i've been thinking about this for a very
very long time and worrying for all my
my entire career i've always wanted to
kind of get to this point where i wanted
to
make a life form and understand i've
made it right so there's a big problem
right now is like i could go in my lab
and say hey brian just come to my lab
isn't it cool we've got chemistry and
we'll be like cool chemistry even looks
like you've got some
life form and they'll say well i've got
this life form look and you'll be like
we'll prove it i mean how do i know that
this is it done anything you're just not
faking me out you haven't just added
something in and i think that that's um
that process you described how can we
allow the idea to to be
played with so what is my what is my
theory so my theory is
that selection occurs in the universe
naturally
but until you make organic molecule well
until you make molecules that can store
information by happenstance
that um you can't get selection so what
i need is molecules
and then i get selection and selection
acts on a commentary explosion and then
reduces it somehow in a network and
start to produce a dynamic or in get
selection you're like rightly great
great idea you know ether cogs how do we
do it
so what i realized many years ago and i
and i i suppose i invented the theory
much longer ago than i'd actually
realized i invented a theory called
assembly theory
and it came like this which was um
um i got really fed up with information
theory in physics and computer science
because everyone kept
using the observer the god in the
physics was the observer looking down
and counting and assigning states
and i was like well
imagine the observer emerges
so what i wanted to try and do is to say
okay
if i wanna if i find a molecule
um how do i know that molecule and this
is the bad word but well now because we
talked about jim taur and the steel mat
are still manning things how do i know
the molecule has had a creator
or has been created by an evolutionary
dynamic or is produced randomly
and this actually this was a question i
paid played with for many many years and
what i realized and i'll take a segue so
i'm going to go back because the problem
is this
we have some people saying there's
phosphine on venus as evidence of life
could be
but does life on earth produce phosphine
no
not really
not at all in fact not proven
weird yeah yeah it's we've found it
associated with my basically phosphate
in is produced when you have a reducing
agent and some phosphate
so they found phosphine in feast bird
feces and in some bacterial mats of
course it's reducing agent you add it to
phosphate it makes a smell that's not
the same thing as saying biology makes
phosphine because it doesn't biology
makes carbon dioxide oxygen methane all
sorts of things but it doesn't really
make phosphate it might by accident make
phosphine but not by design so then
you've got but then there's an argument
right let's not dismiss it let's say
phosphine is a viable biomarker then
let's talk about the viking mission then
let's talk about arsenic dna all these
things suffer from the same problem so i
was inspired by the cern
machine how they are brilliant right
we've got this thing we've got this
theory of you know the way the universe
works right there's the standard model
play with a standard model a bit and we
can simulate how that standard model may
work
now if we've got a simulation we can
build an experiment
now build an experiment and we know what
energy range to go to and then for like
30 or 40 years like yeah good energy
range thanks to that two billion euros
or deutsche mark or pounds can you give
us another fight we'll get the higgs you
know we'll go to 128 point whatever gv
and we'll find it and i was like oh gosh
we don't have a standard model of life
we don't have a so we don't have a
theory of life we don't have a model we
don't have a machine so i've taken the
bold step and said right my model was
selection
in the universe in molecules
i'm now going to say how much do i need
to simulate it and i'm going to think
about to then
have a simulator
and then i'm going to make a machine in
my lab and i need a detector in your
case it's detecting a peak
energy spectrum or whatever
i'm going to detect complexity how do i
do it and that's how it came in the
molecular complexity idea and i work
backwards i said right i'm going to take
molecules i can only find in biology
let's take natural products so if we
take something like taxol taxol's
relatively big molecule
and the formula is like let's say let's
say 62 heavy atoms and they have to be
in one configuration the chance of you
getting those atoms together in that
configuration
is basically
infinitesimally small one less than one
in a mole
so what that means if you find taxol
um
in any detectable amount there must be a
process that made it
and so and can i then detect the
complexity of taxol well yeah i use an
instrument i made in my lab it uses a
thing called a mass spectrometer and you
cut the molecule up into fragments it's
a bit like you take an iphone and hit it
with a hammer gently enough to not
destroy it but to break it open so you
can count the pieces and go oh there's
something in there boom can't break it
and you can select the iphones
so what i've come up with is a way of
determining the intrinsic complexity of
a molecule
and i'm making a metric for it and
that's what we we did for astrobiology
and we're now using this system to go
and look for life in the lab and i'm
pretty confident that we will generate
evolutionary dynamics and then larger
that scale so so how we tested it i'm
kind of jumping a bit we had this theory
for the um for the complexity of
molecules it's intrinsic you do not need
to know anything about the molecule
it just tells you about the number of
different bonds so you select the
molecule
that's one thing
then we then went and looked at and we
just took six million compounds from
around the planet and just characterize
them
and we then took a load of sample we
then went to the lab and so we got
molecules from of all the complexity
scale and measured it using mass effect
did the actual experiment did the theory
we got a nice correlation then we then
got a load of samples from outer space
around the earth and biology nasa gave
us samples and they even blinded it
because they didn't believe us they gave
us murchison
and we used the detection system and we
found long story short that everything
that was abiotic or dead had a low
complexity or assembly number less than
15
and stuff that was alive had the
assembly number going all the way up
and it almost had like a threshold on
earth and getting that paper published
was so difficult because everybody all
the chemists said this is impossible we
don't believe we don't believe that
complexity you need
complexity can happen for free in
chemistry so i say it's like saying so
the chemist was saying to me the
referees were saying oh no we're allowed
to break the second law if we can get
information for free
so i was i actually found myself saying
to the editor hey guys we haven't in we
have an intelligent design problem in
chemistry
but chem synthetic chemists are
put and
obviously they're not it is a cultural
thing
and chemists are used to making
molecules to say to chemists molecules
on earth
that that aren't touched humans or
biology hands are really simple it's
really a hard thing to grasp or accept
so that's kind of how we've got around
it we've i've had to make my own theory
my own model and the molecular
complexity is now out there and people
are
hopefully going to try and break it and
use it
so in
that fascinating same vein you your
group your collaborator sarah walker and
others you're the last author on it but
maybe you should you should talk about
what that means uh in in science but
it's called identifying molecules as bio
signatures with assembly theory and mass
spectrometry um this is a paper in
nature which starts off with the word
alien in it and what do you make first
of all leave all this fascination that
is in the zeitgeist about alien life
yeah i think well there's there's a
really interesting cultural debate going
on right now in like the with the u.s
releasing all these reports and and what
i try to do and talk to people about
ufos and aliens is to say well hey hang
on um
is it likely that ufos have been
visiting us maybe not but let's not be
too dismissive but let's understand what
it is that you're interested in
and i think rather than me being as
dismissive to the
ufo
kind of believer as to the intelligent
design believer and say hey what are you
looking for why are you interested
because the the thing that i met i think
maybe the thing i missed with jim is to
not just to argue from a point of view
of science is going to solve the problem
and say ah
you want meaning as much as i do and in
the ufo i think the ufo thing right now
is exposing
you know people kind of how they react
and let's say we are successful we
understand let's say we understand the
origin of the universe where life is
likely to be and we find new life forms
how is that gonna or we make it on earth
how is that gonna affect humanity in our
society
so i actually think that the current
zeitgeist is really interesting although
i think it's unlikely that ufos are
visiting earth for all sorts of good
reasons that you've debated and i i'm
certainly um you know i'm not going to
say that things are the impossible is
really impossible because let's not do
that that would be against the podcast
after all but i would like
with what i think i like to think about
with the bounds of possibility so i
think that people really want to know
this stuff they want to know if they're
alone in the universe they want to know
if aliens are exist so if i can use if i
can make an alien in my lab like as in
an alien a new life form that uses
different elements and looks different
that will be profound if i can then help
nasa phi or esa or anyone find life in
the solar system
most likely in the outer solar system
i'm willing to bet
um your house
necessarily my house
on the fact that chemistry will be
different
really sure
and if we find that it's going to tell
us something really profound about
our place in the universe and our own
meaning and i think you know jim and you
and myself and my colleagues were all
entitled to our own little bit of
meaning but let's share it in such a way
that we can expand our horizons because
we need to understand where humanity is
going if life is a planetary process and
global warming is a result of everything
that's going on how can we work together
to avert
the coming problems associated with it
how can we do all these sorts of
interesting things so the fundamental
science meaning that we get paid for
what we would do for free as your point
in the beginning suddenly becomes really
relevant to people saying well what am i
what am i doing here um and i love doing
that i mean i love that debate and i
think it's important to be open-minded
and respectful
yes indeed it is uh let's talk about
this paper we only have a few minutes
left uh in this fascinating
conversation we're going to have many
more i hope maybe in person someday um
identifying molecules as biosignatures
uh leading off with the word alien in
the very first sentence which is rare i
i mean i've had a lot of papers rejected
from from nature um maybe i should put
um put aliens in the title or in the
abstract um talk about this
making de novo life in the laboratory
and what is this possibility
that you and sarah and your wonderful
team
have have really maybe unlocked for for
potential use for the first time in
history yeah i mean it is a big team
effort and i'm i think it's really
interesting the way it's come about
because i think that um
i i like kind of the collaboration with
sarah's team because they were they're
just really interesting and life is a
phenomena and and willing to kind of
take a step back
and in my own team when i developed
assembly theory i think i developed it
on my own right it's the one thing i
developed one day walking down the
street and
about and then i had to then work and it
was just one of those ideas and ideas
are cheap we all know that but then with
my team
they then basically wrote the algorithms
did the mass spectate and we validated
the theory with sarah's team we got nasa
involved so all of that teamwork really
came together nicely and it allowed us
to really put down three key points we
allowed to come up with a new theory of
assembly which i think is going to be
it's not just about it's going to
replace entropy right
we're going to stop using entropy and
we're going to start looking at assembly
which is going to really mess people up
for a while i'm not saying entropy
entropy just tells you what you lost
assembly tells you what you have
which is kind of cool because there is
no in assembly theory what it does it
basically i haven't actually explained
what the what the theory is the theory
says if i've got a given complex object
um
or if i've got a given object and i
break it into its atoms being atoms or
lego bricks
what is the shortest unique way i can
get to that object
right by doing the least number of
symmetry operations
so and so and i'm allowed once i know a
piece of a can make a motif
that exists in the memory the lineage so
it's a bit like um so the way you would
take take the word abracadabra
you then i actually got the word
abracadabra into one of the figures of
the paper and i show that abracadabra
you can actually make by putting all the
letters today or you can say take an a b
and rna and then put it all together and
show the assembly of abracadabra so what
assembly theory is it's like what you'd
call commodore of complexity which is
like look at how what is the smallest
programmer you could use to write it
but it does something different common
goal of complexity requires an observer
what assembly theory says is what is the
minimum steps i need to make on a on a
random walk
so it gives you a lower bound to make
the molecule so the number of steps
so what we did probabilistically is if
you do more than 15 steps unique steps
the chances of you doing that in the
molecular space is less than one in a
mole
so a mole is the number of molecules
in a in a mole of say of of the compound
so if you take water the molecular
weight of water because it's h2o two
hydrogens and one oxygen is 18.
18 mils of water is 18 grams in 18 grams
of water that there are 6.022 times 10
to the 23 molecules that's a lot of
molecules so with a molecule assembly
number of 15 or higher
there would be only one molecule in that
in that mole that would have that
assembly number
so that then allows us to give us the
probability and then we then did the
probability got the model and then went
into the lab and actually developed the
experiment and we in this paper we use
mass spectrometry but we also showed it
can work for infrared
now this is where suddenly
the astronomers start to go we can start
to observe infrared of exoplanets
maybe we can start to look at high
assembly in exoplanets one day and stop
worrying about you know one-off markers
so this kind of entire
paper allowed us to say posit a theory
have a model and then have a test apply
it as a life detection but really sarah
and i are going much deeper
assembly theory tells you about
how physics turns into chemistry and how
chemistry turns into biology
that is fascinating and of course the
ultimate issues of life and lee we could
talk for hours but i don't want to miss
the final thrilling three
questions that i ask all my treasured
and uh guests that honor me with their
presence and so i will now ask you lee
are you ready to go into the impossible
yes all right my friend
we begin with uh the end of your life
which will happily hopefully not occur
maybe ever but certainly not until the
biblical age for righteous people which
is 120 years uh that's the age moses
lived to for those of you questioning at
home
uh and i want to ask you when you depart
this mortal coil as the bard said
uh what would you put in your ethical
will not your material will where all
that funding goes to your your students
so they can keep the lab going but where
would you rank what would you put in
your ethical will for the influence to
the betterment of humanity after you're
gone
um i would like to make sure or put in
my ethical will that
enough information that would change the
future of the universe right in terms of
the ability to make humanity more
sustainable on earth or to make sure we
could generate um origin of life
algorithms so we can make sure that our
culture or some i you know i'm turning
into ridley scott right that terrible
movie prometheus but uh finding some way
of changing the future state of the
universe in a way that makes life more
exciting for our children and their
children and more sustainable but i
think making it exciting because what
life seems to do is it likes to make
things more complicated and more
interesting so if i could do anything to
make that
happen in a good way uh rather than the
destructive day the destruction that
some people do that would be my that
would be my dream and maybe that
dovetails nicely into the next question
which is about the uh far future of all
of humanity not just specifically uh
those of your biological and ideological
progeny and that has to do with what
arthur c clarke had and the sentinel uh
monolith these kind of strange almost
menacing objects that uh that persist
and are first encountered by early
hominids in the plains of africa and
later are found on the moon and we don't
really know what they're for maybe
they're a time capsule maybe they're a
warning um what would you put on such a
billion-year-long lasting time capsule
what was the culmination perhaps of of
scientific knowledge that has been
accrued that you would like to preserve
for all time
um i so i think this is a bit weird but
i saw it the the somehow i'd like to
capture in some kind of motif the
ability for a life form to take a selfie
because i think that concept we don't
yet understand consciousness but it
isn't interesting that we all like
tilting selfies so if i could somehow
immortalize that now i'm doing that now
i'm going to put it on
i've got a tick tock or the equivalent
of tick tock on that monolith i don't
think you've ever had an answer like
that before but no
the ability to self-reference
if i could find an object in the
universe and say my gosh this object is
the product of self-reference
oh no i'm not alone in the universe it
wasn't unlike the universe did something
for me
it's like john archibald wheeler's
universe looking at itself with an
eyeball over the letter u yeah exactly
which is
a diagram so simple even i can recreate
it on occasion lee the last question
involves the name of this podcast and
now we're going to go backwards in time
violating the second law of
thermodynamics you love and treasure so
much no no comment okay going backwards
in time sir arthur c clarke's third law
states the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to venture a
little way past them into the impossible
that's the origin of my podcast name
where i am here at uc san diego the
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
i want to ask you lee what mysterious
aspect of life perplexed you as a 20
year old a 30 year old whatever what
epiphany what great moments of clarity
would you tell to your former self to
give you the courage to go into the
impossible advice to your former self
um i think i've yeah i've taken the
advice but later is having more
confidence to um
expose
my mathematical intuition when i was
much earlier because actually it's quite
although i'm relatively reasonable
chemist now i think it's quite hard for
people to take my graph theory seriously
because it's something that
mathematicians do when they're really
young and for someone to have a new
insight in their late 40s it's kind of
you know it's a bit late but but i think
the experiments will work and that's
fine but i would say if i could just
have the confidence to basically be even
more bashful
and um fearless than i was i would just
maybe have done that a little bit more
earlier i really love cutting across the
disciplines
i just wish i'd done it earlier
welly i'm thankful you did it at all
some people never do it and i'm so glad
to know you we're connected to you on
clubhouse and twitter wherever else
we're connected
i want to thank you for sharing some of
your insight your foresight into our
most important questions the biggest
issues in cosmology in physics and
biology and chemistry and beyond thank
you for sharing that with my audience
and thank you for being a friend of
science
thank you very much for having me on
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you